you know it's only just a second of us
[ __ ] it but maybe it's just me but I've
had a lot of time to think about this
and I really think we could be PD next
power couple you know like Regis and
Kathie Martha and Snoopy Ellie and Sean
I like where your head's at but I
actually have to go like leave I have
the opportunity of a lifetime I have to
go to the airport my uber is out in
front and I hate to leave you hanging
like this but you're gonna have to drive
on Episode two I'm so sorry to do this
to you I have all the confidence in the
world in you Elliot where are you going
no details what's going on world's the
first we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at
you with a very special report from
cloggy London town we're finally here to
meet the chicken connoisseur well any
cool we're here at chicken town we're
going to do some lunch we're going to
catch up but first prep yet ready to get
it crackin yeah let's go
[Music]
so I'm excited that we can finally sit
down together because I feel like in our
YouTube channels we have a lot of
similarities you know we started off as
a goof we never thought it would get
that big are you the same way yeah like
we didn't it was never meant to be
really that serious it was kind of more
of a joke but we go chicken shop anyway
like regularly so before we might as
well just film it I'll be in a suit sofa
well just for a laugh like just stuff
that lots of people get like they all
understand if you were going to chicken
shop in the zoo in that but like yeah I
didn't expect it to go mainstream at all
if you come here expecting let the
pengus much yah yah yah yah yah yah
chicken connoisseur when I watch you on
like this is a food critic for the
people yeah that was kind of the point
just like just to review like regular
foods for regular people and this places
they could all go as well it's not like
I'm going to like some ridiculously
price restaurant and stuff because there
are a lot of reviews for those places
and I'm thinking you eat there no way I
know anyway so are you enjoying the ride
are there things that are bothering you
about all this new attention that's
being channeled towards the chicken
connoisseur whoa it's all the Salem
adness like because in my head I knew
even if they did blow up like people
just be like oh yeah you're researching
that's cool but like it's got a lot
madder than that I wouldn't say I'm
necessarily enjoying it it's kind of
wish it died down a bit on my road
hasn't spotted a few times but like
sometimes they do have to resort to out
like a balaclava it's good though that
you stick to your guns and it takes some
courage because most food critics right
they want to remain anonymous or as
anonymous as they can so that when they
go into the restaurant they get an
authentic dining experience ultimately
even like some places out fences and I
ate the food and I wasn't impressed
like it wasn't nice like for me to say
that now is a problem they see that
they're thinking about suing me
yeah they give them beverages yeah okay
and I don't know it doesn't make sense
because anyone can go there anyone can
say like that through the dead
like worse tinnitus everything I say is
putting justified as far as I'm
concerned yeah I don't know my opinion
suddenly become like make or break with
everything I think is a bit much
this is my first time in London the
sheer number of chicken spots there all
over the place can you talk about that
because I was not ready for that idea
that was that deep into the culture I
don't know it's hard for me to say
because they've been around longer than
I've been around but the ones I opened
in now like the newer ones are not
really the regular average chicken shop
that's kind of more high-end more kind
of hit fresh ones there's a lot of them
actually yeah opening up all over the
place but yeah local boss man still
there so basically I came to London to
have lunch with the chicken connoisseur
Howie cool I'll see you soon damn okay
Sean you know I thought when you first
left me alone here I was like pretty sad
about it but then you come with the
chicken connoisseur power move all right
I wish I was there though with you guys
I wish you told me about the trip before
you left anyway I'm here to hold things
down I can do this I don't need Sean I
don't need him for third and fourth
fifth episode well for right now get
this show on the road show me some flips
fat boy SS see if you don't know him
you're gonna know him after this he reps
McDonald's hard he made a diss track
against Burger King and he [ __ ] loves
cookies from Subway
he's drawing cookies [ __ ] Katie like
if I was the guy working at Subway's
like I would guess the nilly be just
like a little bit scared that wasn't a
simple throw that will literally bite
though I [ __ ] love the [ __ ] fat boy
sfe if you watch his videos he's at the
gym he's on the treadmill and he's like
running you're like man you're getting
into shape I really like it then he gets
off and he's like a huge big mass I mean
this guy is crazy but also really
lovable you know to mean like a teddy
bear just wanna like hug him
last week we debate about fries but
today I need to vent about the $2,000
priced pizza industry kitchen why
because there's a load of [ __ ] I
need to talk about it there's a million
on one reasons why I hate this Pizza
number one it's $2,000 this pizza dough
is made from squid ink the cheese is
from England
it has fog wall in it 24k gold sprinkles
all over it I mean the whole thing is
ridiculous did you make this for
Instagram so that these girls can come
and be like look at me I'm eating a $250
slave it has caviar from the Caspian Sea
like no one gives a [ __ ] where is the
Caspian Sea never even a caviar from a
goddamn [ __ ] can let alone my goddamn
pizza happy sorry
don't eat that cuz I will episode 2 in
the books we're going to get better and
better and I just feel really
comfortable and really great maybe Sean
doesn't have to come back he'll come
back episode 3 me and Sean next Tuesday
11:00 a.m. le ly a mouse mash
you
now is it
bro
you